and brought on a social media yes yeah
well we have a whole team with people
who are doing wonderful wonderful things
for us and so so you know Leah are is
helping us integrate them and just him
and there's a visiting people EJ and you
know and just many many people on our
team you're drexler the neil gaiman arm
you know it's like every department
someone has shown up who's just
spectacular and you know end and more
the more the merrier you know if someone
comes with a good heart and the ability
to do something yes it takes an army and
they say it takes a village but it's a
village the know stuff and you can't do
it alone it's impossible if you know if
I was a novel sitting in a room at least
write novels and I didn't fewer people
but with film and TV no it takes it
takes a ton of people you know and in a
lot in but that's great people are eager
to help yeah I'm very grateful to
everyone
and what is the process you go through
in terms of finding these people are
getting them involved I use my hip no
ray it's like this big turning vehicle
and they just kind of come with his
glassy eyes no it's it's it's what I do
is have for many years for 19 years I've
been running around table of writers and
directors and actors and producers and
composers and novelists it started 19
years ago when my friends were feeling
bummed out in Hollywood and they were
just isolated and sad and depressed and
and I realized I could either do
something about it or just complain and
let set up is going to do something
about it I started a roundtable where
we'd meet every Thursday so people
wouldn't have to remember which thursday
we meet at a restaurant and and we would
go around the table and everyone would
have about five minutes to talk about
what they were doing and we would then
hook them up with whatever they need it
and everyone will be treated the same
whether they were Oscar winners or just
starting out they will be treated with
the same amount of respect and there'd
be no judgment as the project I mean
someone wanted someone to read a script
and give no it's fine but you but no one
would ever say oh well you're stupid to
be doing Western or you know or that's a
silly idea that would not be allowed
because it's not judgment of material
ever unless someone asks for it so it
started with six people and now at
several thousand and it we've offshoots
in the New York Dallas Phoenix San
Francisco Santa Barbara one starting in
London would start in New Orleans and
and so you can send one email out it
goes out to all thousand plus members
and it's it's we've thrived and we
benefited from each other so it started
with me just putting out the word to the
table and to my friends in the industry
and starting to build it it started with
Neil Johnson and Doug Drexler my
friends were science fiction directors
and Doug's a special effects guy from
Galactica and then I just started
looking at people who would show up and
but you also look for talents so sprint
since David Ray klijn is our composure
the transgene isn't helping design our
campaign and so when I saw they was
brilliant at it it's like okay you want
to be a co-producer you're promoted
you know all right so and then and then
other people would show up and then you
start to see who's just talking and not
delivering versus who's actually doing
it and and the only thing you do is you
make course corrections very quickly
because you it's a two month campaign
you can't wait for six months down the
road to see if someone's oh did done the
other thing they said they were going to
do and you know but our team is you know
they're people in their 70s helping us
there are people who are kids were in
their teens helping us and you know all
aboard be that
it's fun that they're all welcome on the
spaceship set
you